[Musik]
die mille miglia ein mekka für oldtimer
fans
[Musik]
startschuss ist in brescia in
norditalien
von hier geht es einmal nach rom und
zurück
mit dabei auch ellen lohr und sophia
porsche mercedes 300 sl baujahr 1957
die beiden sind vom beruf
rennfahrerinnen in den teuren oldtimer
den sie zum ersten mal gemeinsam auf
eine rally
[Musik]
vier tage lang quer durch italien
ich bin 18 jahre alt vom beteiligen
können wir jetzt für mercedes an den
start
[Musik]
die werde generation
die zweite generation zu
nicht professionellen motorsport
echte herausforderung für uns beide
in 18 jahren sind tolles zwei millionen
auto zu fahren ellen lohr ist eine der
erfolgreichsten rennfahrerinnen europas
und sophia flash der shooting-star der
einen dramatischen unfall in macao
letztes jahr mit viel glück überlebte
sie träumt von einer formel-1-karriere
und lässt es sich nicht nehmen bei der
mille miglia hinterm lenkrad zu sitzen
[Musik]
insgesamt sollten die auch erfahren ich
bin 18
ich darf so ein auto fahren was glaubst
du die sache geklärt ich saß auf meinem
co driver sieht er aber ich habe mich
sagen wir mal erinnert dass ich genauso
als co-pilotin muss ellen lohr die
richtige strecke finden die das roadbook
die organisatoren vorgibt
ansonsten gilt
durchschnittsgeschwindigkeit einheiten
und vor allem das alte auto heil ins
ziel bringen
[Musik]
langscheid
bis zu 14 stunden sind sie auf einer
etappe unterwegs und das immer voll
konzentriert
eine kurze unachtsamkeit und schon hat
man sich verfahren
[Musik]
wie ist das schön gelöst und alle waren
irgendwie zusammen da hat mir so einen
6er reihe nur als eltern selbst familie
ist gerade dieser schlange
ein volksfest für die italiener kinder
bekommen schulfrei um den autos
zuzuwinken seit 1927 findet die rallye
statt
früher saß nur männer am steuer erst in
den letzten jahren kamen die ersten
frauen teams dazu
frauen fahren viel besser als männer
denn wenn wir am steuer sind dann geben
wir auch gas wir wollen die vibrationen
und die ganze kraft des motors spüren
super ich würde auch sofort so ein auto
fahren
die fahrt durch die emilia romagna durch
umbrien und durch die toskana ist ein
erlebnis für alle sinne
[Musik]
die routinierte rennfahrerin ellen lohr
nimmt bereits zum vierten mal an der
mille miglia teil
und sie muss ich eingestehen dass ihre
junge kollegin ihr in einem punkt weit
voraus ist
ich habe so viel gelernt dass man
hochkonzentriert fahren kann und
trotzdem diverse millionen instagram
channels bedienen kann
sophia flash versucht mit ihren post vor
allem frauen für diesen motor sport zu
begeistern damit in den nächsten jahren
mehr frauen teams bei der mille miglia
dabei sein werden